hello everybody and welcome to part 8 of
oh shut up Billy I already heard this
this is part 8 you don't need to hear
this because you're already verbal
listen to me don't listen to Billy part
8 I was wrong because my brain was a
little frazzled from really charming
more like got in my brain I'm a
Montgomery shut up about the gas tank oh
god you're so dumb oh by the way you can
call me Billy it's not my name you
understand but Billy [ __ ] I'm sure you
would agree the name rather similar to a
car do should have a gene with one ha ha
ha go get away get away get away all
right that's a good start glad I got out
out of the way we got it there the other
dog over here oh look at your little
puppy alright come on bring on I'm not
afraid of you not afraid of you puppy
look sister oh hell no puppy hello why
don't you go way over there don't you go
ah go way over there ah don't come after
me yeah run away you so stupid huh oh
man you're dumb alright watch these leap
moves
oh yeah jump oh yeah oh yeah I'm smart
ha ha ha oh you're so dumb doggy
I'll look at you oh yeah oh so smart
what do we got here oh let me drop this
on your head BAM Oh missed come on one
more try oh yeah come on come on come on
come on come on
no a little more no more over here over
here over here bab-oh mist
now whatever it don't matter I'm still
gonna outsmart you ah
oh is that whoa is that all
I suddenly crouched and you can't find
me that's the way it is
oh I guess this is super stealth mode
when everything goes blue oh yeah I'm so
sneaky where am i where am I
no oh you still see me ah ah no I think
I needed that did that kill you up oh
come on
Oh what the [ __ ] No another dog oh no
bad there's a box I can jump on ha ha I
get out of me ah what am i doing what am
i noon where are we going oh why are
there two dogs oh I'm jerky
I have jerky go get their jerky go get
the jerky ether jerky jerky it's right
there Oh Oh what are we gonna do
Oh what are we gonna what am i I'll go
away go away ah can I beat you with up
you know [ __ ] face with a hammer
oh yeah oh yeah take that coming would
you want some more
yup here BAM ah yep oh yeah yeah all in
the face
get down huh ah ah no you know give me
give me my back go back
ahh I can never back oh you [ __ ] oh you
[ __ ] I hate you I hate you I hate you
Oh give me pain kills oh oh it looks so
painful ah ah get get down BAM oh [ __ ]
you oh [ __ ] you go away go yeah go away
ah the nerve
ah I'm out of here
I'm out of here
I mean some people are just so rude
jiminy Christmas
oh this looks good hey those holes in my
mind are increasingly gaping yeah Billy
not reach the inner sanctum of the
places I'm not another inner Sanjay way
is blocked so I wanted to squash your
material between my ear to squash you
the most oh shut up Billy Billy no
they're not Billy that wasn't in the
nose and in the words no ad-libbing
Billy Oh Billy I hope your what a puppy
those puppies out there uh-huh sense of
morality it's better company than I
because now it is all you here for Liv
who are you talking to oh you're so
crazy Billy ah but I bet you're great at
parties uh-huh clutching oh shut up
Billy oh sure Oh what is with you and
[ __ ] I'm sorry they say but I think we
are both the sorrier than we are saved
yeah what I gotta lies between your word
plays a pathetic Billy oh the storage
room oh shut up
all right bromine acid I made ammonia
nh3 hydrochloric acid standard
hallucinogens oh boy boy boy
blablablablabla I'll read it later when
I need to know something important all
right broken ladder oh I can take it I
will take it okay apparently that's
where I need to dig all right whatever I
need to dig there they're these weird
ladder pieces noted mental notes on
everything I'm keeping track I can hold
a great deal wait I should keep that in
mind I'm not getting stuck on another
puzzle again so to test things I'm just
gonna whack everything look at
everything
Oh 20 years old okay
looks better Nick and Nick what uh I
don't care I don't care don't care don't
care don't care all right okay
everything in here has been duly noted
mental notes on everything I will not be
running in circles what's this cool
stuff
not very right uh come here doggies I'm
ready for you
bring it on bring it on bring it on
bring it on ha ha ha oh yeah Oh trick
your son out so ah ah ah trick me trick
me you trick me
ah ok ok - [ __ ] - sit - sit - sit George
do sit ah which way uh-huh yeah yeah I
got this I got this
oh I'm so great oh yeah look at me go Oh
like a auxilary shaft ha ha ah
- [ __ ] that way don't lose him oh yeah
ah yeah I'm I'm the best oh yeah that's
why you watch my channel cuz I'm so
great
ah bring it on ok get batteries flare
this note looks important xeno rip aw
aliens I knew it
there are aliens everything in this
place is aliens oh boy
ok alright alright I saw that looks
important yes awesome what's this boo
what's going on here uh-huh okay shaky
shaky shaky I don't see the point okay
looking up high on ah yeah see I learned
my lesson up on things
ah get over here
there yeah mine yeah [ __ ]
alright everything let me double-check
so I don't come back here I got
everything I needed
correct correct
alright duly noted cement mixer if I
need to mix some cement I have no idea
ah okay where's the doggy move at the
auxilary chef no I'm gonna storage
storage oh shut up dog cares about you
oh my god is that the map oh okay there
am i storage okay all right
yeah ah ah it's a block from the other
side no way in fan-fucking-tastic yeah
alright okay I been to excavation I know
all about that I need to go to the
auxilary shaft because that's the only
other place so I go down this hall
through that hall turn on right left
right left left left right I remember
that right left
right hi doggie Oh dougie gimme gimme
gimme gimme
aah no aah oh [ __ ] you get ready BB face
smacked oh I bet I blow it up oh oh ok
yeah yeah oh come here come here Joel
just give me an 8 just give me a chance
I'll just give me the chance
I'll give me the chance oh you're gonna
be [ __ ] on a pile of being stacked
that that's good - what what are you
doing what are you doing what gotta see
what do you do what do you what really
what I don't know I don't know oh you're
stuck okay I'll just ah there you are
I'll get good gimmick all yeah all that
hurt but it did added a wound to your
manymoon oh yeah it's one more to the
face or to the ass oh did that hurt
oh I killed it oh I can kill things yeah
oh yeah Oh what [ __ ] was that
alright whatever
come on nothing uh bunk ah ah yeah boom
oh yeah that did it
no no oh it's it was an explosion would
shouldn't be able to handle that uh okay
all right okay all right I can do this I
can deal with this
found a great door leading deeper into
the complex but it's barricaded with a
piece of wood on the other side he's
someone I have a broom oh yeah I got a
stick a broom oh please I'll please be
the reason oh why isn't that working all
this dog corpse I can't on us in the way
ah
oh no oh no no oh I got it
hi this is this tricky I'm gonna hit it
pick it up chuck it over and then yeah
this totally gonna work
totally totally gonna work oh [ __ ] put
it away put away put away the hammer let
away the hammer
what walk it off oh I don't even know I
I don't even know [ __ ] this I'm losing
blood
whatever oh all right I gotta pause it
here thanks so much for watching and
this is part 8 I corrected myself at the
beginning so I will see you guys in part
9 of let's play penumbra overture bye
bye